[Music]
in one of the most dramatic elections of
recent times Labour's Redwall tend to
dust and they suffered their worst
defeat since 1935 the party has lost its
way their leadership arrogantly believed
that they knew better many of their
policies were laughable their spending
plans were away with the fairies and
their party has been investigated for
racism it is no wonder that they got a
kicking wary of an MMA ring alas we need
the Labour Party to regroup for a
healthy democracy it is essential that
we have a credible and dare I quote to
resume a strong and stable opposition
see what I did there the only way this
is possible is if they avoid Corbin 2.0
and instead have a radical change from
its current intense socialist agenda and
fairytale spending funds they need to
learn lessons from this disaster and get
back to doing what they do best
represent the everyman
I said I can't help feeling that this is
going to be academic for five possibly
ten years because I don't think that
they necessarily are going to come up
with somebody who is going to be able to
rebuild the where red wall that crumbled
to dust in December it's going to be
very interesting because there's a I
think we can all join the Labour Party
and vote for candidates who we like the
cut of their jib it's very important
that there is a credible opposition that
is going to interrogate this government
in everything it does because the last
thing we need is an elected dictatorship
however this government has already cast
itself as the People's Government all
the Labour candidates are going to cast
themselves as people's candidates so
let's just hear from one who I
personally like and would encourage her
to stand and it's just Philips
we lost the last general election is
because people didn't trust us to govern
and whether that was about leadership
whether that was about message whether
that was about what we were offering or
if we were offering so much that people
felt like it it just wasn't possible so
much of politics is about how people
feel about the street they live on how
they feel in in their hearts and their
bellies about whether their kids are
safe or that they don't like the
homelessness on the streets where they
live we have got to we have got to elect
somebody who can speak to people's
hearts we've got to elect somebody who's
an electable credible opposition let's
have a look at the runners and riders
shall we here we go here's the list from
left to right
circus Tama then Jess Phillips from whom
we just heard then Clive Lewis Emily
Thornbury Lisa Nandi and Rebecca long
Bailey that is at the time of taping
that could even be another arrival and
Barry Gardner who's still yet to make
his decision you know what I wonder and
Greg this is possibly one for you
because you and I are off that and
possibly Rachel
I wonder if actually whoever this part
whoever the list leader is has to do a
clinic which is effectively detoxify the
party take all the hit then fall on his
or her sword and that comes whoever the
next Blair might be great possibly
possibly
I mean if it's if it's basically the
left that staying control of the party
the hard left well that would be
remained long babe that would be Rebecca
and Bailey I think it's the end of the
Labour Party I think though people have
been saying that for it's not far off
this was a disastrous worse than Michael
thought it was the disastrous result all
that yeah man I did a white in London
it's not it but outside they were
terrible being chosen successor wings
give up yeah it's over but I would say
the same as kiss Thomas sir kissed on
the architect of Labour's bricks it
policy another London
Labour MP that's gonna play on the
streets of record I'm sure I think here
star Matt Lee as an intelligence and I
think with some others but I mean I
don't think I don't think you can have
somebody who says we we had
thank you the right policies but somehow
we didn't for me let's just get this out
of the way on the brexit policy for the
majority the last three years Labour's
brexit policy was basically soft brexit
staying in a single market and no chance
of a people's vote now that if you've
got your 71% of labour voters vote and
remain and your 29% that wanted to leave
the EU late may leave having more
control if you're offering a brexit that
takes us out of the EU I mean they have
less control because we no longer be EU
members you annoy pretty much your
entire voter base so labour could not
have committed to it directly so I do
believe the neck leader have to be
somebody who's on the people's vote side
outside of that even she really really
clear Boris Johnson has a year to
negotiate a deal that is significantly
more complicated than the one that took
me three three ways so which means by
the end of this year and certainly by
2024 the country will on the whole be
very clear as to whether naproxen was a
good idea or a bad idea and the damage
would have set in I don't so I disagree
with you I couldn't tell you how that I
think I think the by 2025 thing you know
five years and I think it will be a
yesterday's yesterday's issue but people
yes the decision which is why I don't
necessarily think the lower parties
devastated by it I just don't think that
is I think they can come back but they
can't come back if you're gonna again
have the knee joke what I will use to
call the shots the old jock is in
control because that's you that's not
what the population is and what's not
what they want but surely to God you now
accept that brick say it's a done and
dusted thing it's gonna happen
end of story however exit rector that's
going to happen but the point is we're
talking about the next election we're
talking about 2024 and literally I don't
know why we're arguing about this pretty
much all experts in the field say that
that brexit
will leave us worse off so we will know
categorically the brexit has heard this
boost by in the next election at which
point labour needs to be able to say we
gave you a chance to get out of this so
let's put that that's about for one
second the main thing that will win that
election is if the left is united the
fact that we have that we have
essentially in this country one
party on the right and several parties
on the left means that in a
first-past-the-post system the right is
always going to be an added advantage
the best way to ensure that there is a
real possibility of a victory for
left-leaning politics at the next
election is the for the Labour Party to
commit solidly it's not a racial reform
that wasn't to the right but what was
Nigel for it destroys your argument I
like this one party on the right because
because because of the spray the VEX
party did worse than the Greens funded
it's ladies gonna win again they're
gonna have to a take on PR and tunes
they can I have to have a deal with the
Liberals in particular to say you stand
here and will stand there yeah
the days when you could and and the
table that's gonna be very tough for the
Labour Party and it's not what lay but
it's this myth it's survival depends on
it and the only way you're going to get
laid
Lib Dems and greens voting for the
Labour Party is if they see it as a
route to real power at the following
election well there will be you stood as
a candidate tell us what it was tilted
what was not the reaction to you but
what was the reaction was the Labour
Party and how cuz well I was blown away
so in whole it's just simple you might
no one else might even bother you might
know you might as well not even
bothering whole because it is one of
those cities you virt there because your
dad did your granddad did that's how I
did you see the brexit party there's a
principle but tell us about the reaction
you got yes I was I ran for the brexit
party and I ran sounds your question out
of principle because I thought you know
I'm a brexit ear and I knew and I know
and I meant a and there's an awful lot
of people in hall that would not have
gone Tory and to be fair to your brother
and his crew they did a very good job in
neutralizing the threat of the brexit
pie to your point we didn't do very well
at all and that was because she sorely
the strength of the the conservative the
Tories became the brexit yeah
incredibly well but back to your point I
was out door knocking I was out in the
rain the shot everything and I couldn't
believe the response that the Labour
Party was getting there was posters up
in whole saying get labour our you know
people like for the photo because I
stood in 2015-2017 and
got abused left right and center by the
labor activist supporter some of them
and this time around the mood was
completely different labour won they did
win but the euro would only just in some
of the seats and there lost by quite a
big amount that some of their majority
and the mood was completely different so
last time the Labour politicians they're
swooning around like they earned the
place it was their seat there say this
time the mood was significantly
different so I think if you ask them and
to be fair to them some of them only got
elected because I talk a lot of the
votes I took a lot of the verts and I
split the brexit vote so it might be
either joined the Labour Party to vote
in this coming election no so
essentially we have about five years for
the left to sort itself out you're
watching the pledge coming up
I'm saying it's time to take from the
rich and give to the poor
[Music]